[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tortenwelt ich mache heute etwas
saisonales es gibt ja zurzeit ganz viel
Kürbis im Garten oder im Supermarkt und
deswegen gibt's heute ganz leckere
Kürbis Cupcakes und die Kürbis Cupcakes
habe ich mit ganz vielen tollen Gewürzen
gemacht so dass sie richtig schön
herbstlich schmecken und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal die Zutaten für 12
Cupcakes ich habe hier 85 g weiche
Butter 85 g Zucker zwei Eier 40 g
wahnüsse die habe ich bereits gemallen
und da gehen natürlich auch andere Nüsse
einfach das was euch am besten schmeckt
hier habe ich 75 g Mehl 150 g
Kürbispüree das habe ich schon
vorbereitet und zeige euch einfach
gleich wie das funktioniert und hier
habe ich ein paar Gewürze und zwar einen
halben Teelöffel Zimt ein halben
Teelöffel ingwa eine Prise Salz ein
Viertel Teelöffel Nelken und eine halbe
Packung Backpulver und ich brauche für
das Rezept auch noch etwas Muskatnuss
die reibe ich auch frisch und damit das
Ganze noch so ein richtig Crunch damit
das Ganze noch ein richtig crunchigen
Kick hat gebe ich da noch ein paar
wahnüsse rein die sind noch ganz und die
werde ich gleich mit meinen Händen noch
etwas
zerkrömeln zuerst müsst ihr jetzt das
kürbispüe vorbereiten und das
funktioniert so ich habe jetzt hier
einen hokaedo Kürbis und den habe ich
jetzt aus unserem eigenen Garten das
sieht man auch weil da hier einfach
etwas unregelmäßiger ist und so darf ein
Kürbis auch in natur aussehen und diesen
Kürbis verwende ich immer gerne weil man
da die Schale mit verzehren kann und die
Schale nicht noch mühsam wegschälen muss
bei dem Kürbispüree macht ihr das jetzt
so dass ihr den Kürbis natürlich erstmal
waschen müsst und dann klein schneidet
und dann gebt ihr ihn mit ganz wenig
Wasser auf den Herd und lasst ihn da
etwa 20 Minuten lang köcheln bis er
schön weich ist und dann ist auch die
Schale schon schön weich und dann müsst
ihr einfach nur noch mit einem
Pürierstab durchgehen und das ganze
durchpürieren und abkühlen lassen und
dann erhaltet ihr dieses
Kürbispüree was jetzt eben 150 g sind
und es waren ursprünglich auch 150 g
Kürbis ich habe jetzt bereits meine
Muffinform mit Papier ausgekleitet und
habe hier 12 Muffinförmchen drin ihr
könnt aber auch wenn ihr die Cupcakes
kleiner haben wollt einfach eine kleine
cupcakeform mit 24 Stück nehmen das habe
ich auch schon gemacht und dann werden
die Cupcakes richtig süß und klein für
den Teig gebe ich jetzt die Zutaten in
meiner Rührschüssel ihr könnt das ganze
aber auch mit einem elektrischen
Handmixer machen und hier muss jetzt die
Butter einfach schön weich sein damit
man sie schön verrühren
kann so da gebe ich jetzt direkt den
Zucker mit dazu
und lass es so etwa eine Minute lang
rühren wenn sich butter und Zucker dann
etwas vermischt haben kommen die Eier
mit rein und die müssen auch
Zimmertemperatur haben ansonsten wird es
keine schöne homogene
Masse und wenn sich das dann alles
vermischt hat kommen einfach die
restlichen Zutaten mit rein das
abgekühlte
Kürbispüree das muss auch kalt sein denn
sonst gerinnen ja jetzt die Eier und
dann habt ihr Rührteig oder Rührei statt
Rührteig dann das
Mehl die
Walnüsse Backpulver und die
Gewürze und jetzt gebe ich hier noch von
der Muskatnuss rein und je mehr ihr da
dazu reingebt umso würziger wird es aber
so Viertel Teelöffel ist
optimal so und das wird jetzt nur noch
ganz kurz
untergerührt bis sich alles verbunden
hat das war's auch
schon und dann kratze ich das hier noch
ein bisschen ab dass da nichts
verschwendet
und so sollte dann der fertige Teig
Aussehen ihr seht er ist schön cremig
und leicht orange durch die Farbe des
Kürbisses und jetzt nehme ich meine
Walnüsse und zerkleiner sie einfach ganz
grob mit den Fingern und geb sie in
meine vorbereitete Muffinform unten mit
rein und dann haben wir später wenn die
Cupcakes fertig sind so ein bisschen
Biss und einfach die festen Walnüsse
noch drin
und dann nehme ich einfach so einen
Eisportionierer das ist immer perfekt
zum Portionieren und nehme da den Teig
raus so ein bisschen so ein gehäufter
Eisportionierer und gebt es einfach über
die
Walnüsse und so geht es super schnell
und man verkleckert normalerweise
nicht
und so werden dann die Cupcakes bei 175°
für etwa 20 Minuten gebacken auf jeden
Fall müsst ihr da wieder die
Stäbchenprobe machen mit dem Zahnstocher
und dann lassen wir sie schön
Abkühlen meine Cupcakes sind jetzt
gebacken und ich habe sie hier auf
meinem auskühlgitter auskühlen lassen
also sie sind jetzt vollständig kalt
jetzt werde ich noch das Topping machen
und das ist das Topping was ihr auch
schon kennt mein Frischkäse Butter
Topping ich habe jetzt hier 170 g
Frischkäse 170 g Butter und 170 g
Puderzucker wenn ihr ein anderes Topping
machen wollt könnt ihr das natürlich
auch
machen der erste Schritt ist jetzt dass
wir den Puderzucker sieben damit er
keine Klümpchen mehr hat und das mache
ich einfach da
rein
so
und dann gebe ich da noch die Butter mit
dazu und die Butter muss auch hier weich
sein damit sie sich jetzt schön mit dem
Zucker
verbindet zum verrühren nehme ich jetzt
wieder diesen flachen
flexirührer und lass es etwa eine Minute
lang rühren bis die Butter schön
weißcremig
wird
so und jetzt jetzt kommt da einfach noch
der Frischkäse mit rein und wird nur
kurz eingerührt bis sich alles
vollständig verbunden
hat und so sieht dann die fertige
Frischkäse Buttercreme
aus seht sie ist einfach sehr schön
cremig und nicht krisselig und so soll s
auch
aussehen ich habe in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal den Spritzbeutel vorbereitet
ich nehme da jetzt ein Einweg
Spritzbeutel weil die Creme sehr fettig
ist und ich will da einfach kein
Spritzbeutel auswaschen müssen und habe
da jetzt den großen Adapter genommen und
eine große
Lochtülle stecke ich jetzt hier in
meinen spritzbeutelständer rein D habe
ich beide Hände
frei und kann die eme hier
reinfüllen und dann habt ihr hier die
Frischkäsecreme drin könnt es da oben
zudrehen dann habt ihr einen besseren
Druck und könnt sie da vorne einfach
rausspritzen und jetzt nehme ich mir
einen
Cupcake und fange außen
an und gehe von außen in die Mitte ohne
dabei zu viel Creme drauf zuetzen weil
es dann schon extrem süß wird aber
dadurch dass der cupcakeeteig nicht ganz
so süß ist passt es perfekt mit der
Creme
[Musik]
zusammen wenn ihr z.B kleine Cupcakes
gebacken habt ich habe jetzt die gleiche
Menge auch in dieser kleinen
minibackform gemacht dann spritzt ihr
einfach einen Tupfer
drauf und das reicht dann für diese
kleine
Menge ich stelle die Cupcakes jetzt kurz
in den Kühlschrank damit die Creme fest
wird und dann werde ich sie fertig
dekorieren während die Cupcakes jetzt
noch ein bisschen abkühlen möchte ich
noch kleine minikürbisse Formen das
müsst ihr nicht machen aber ich mache
das jetzt einfach mal aus Marzipan
normalerweise arbeite ich ja immer ganz
gern mit Fondant aber ich nehme jetzt
einfach mazipan weil ich da den
Geschmack auch sehr gerne mag natürlich
könnt man hier z.B auch
modellierschokolade nehmen das geht auch
und zum mazepan muss ich jetzt etwas
Puderzucker dazu geben damit man ihn
überhaupt verkneten
kann und das mache ich jetzt einfach
nach Gefühl und knete das jetzt einfach
kurz
ein und ihr merkt dann auch dass das
Marzipan immer fester
wird und wenn es dann so so eine schöne
formbare Konsistenz hat werde ich das
jetzt teilen und zwar möchte ich jetzt
einen Teil orange und einen Teil grün
und dafür nehme ich mir meine
pastenfarben das sind jetzt wieder die
von dekobach und die sind alle azofrei
mittlerweile also
schadstofffrei da muss man jetzt einfach
ein bisschen mehr Farbe
nehmen aber die sind echt
super das Orange habe ich mir jetzt aus
dem Gelb und aus dem rot gemischt und
jetzt forme ich diese orangene Paste zu
einer langen
Rolle so ziemlich
gleichmäßig und es sind vielleicht
insgesamt so etwa 70 g Marzipan und dann
schneide ich mir hier mit einem kleinen
Messer Stückchen
weg und Form die zu einer
Kugel und dann durch einen leichten
Druck mit der Hand
zu so einem so ein bisschen
länglich dann nehme ich ein bisschen
Grün und Form das auch zu einer Kugel
drück ein bisschen platt und setzt das
da oben
dran und wenn es ein bisschen klebt
nimmt ihr euch einfach ein bisschen
Puderzucker
und dann braucht ihr so ein
Modellierwerkzeug mit einer Spitze und
könnt da jetzt die Streifen am Rand
[Musik]
formen und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr da
noch so ein kleinen Stil dran machen das
ist dann halt ein bisschen
[Musik]
millimeterarband und und könnt i da noch
so drauf
kleben so und dann habt ihr
euren winzigen Kürbis und so mache ich
jetzt noch ein paar und setze dann auf
meine Cupcakes drauf und jetzt kann ich
meine Cupcakes fertig dekorieren so
sehen sie ja jetzt aus also so wie
vorhin auch und wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr jetzt z.B noch ein bisschen
Zimtpulver nehmen und das in leicht
drüber
streuen so
oder aber auch ein bisschen Schokolade
drüber
raspeln oder einfach
beides und da könnte man jetzt noch
diese kleinen minikürbisse drauf
setzen oder Sie einfach nur nebendran
Stellen zur
Dekoration und so sehen die Cupcakes
dann fertig aus das Rezept gibt's
natürlich zum Nachlesen auf
tortenwelt.de und ich finde auch wenn
ihr keine kürbisfans seid müsst ihr das
Rezept trotzdem mal ausprobieren weil
man den Kürbis da gar nicht raus
schmeckt und außerdem ist ja noch das
Topping mit dabei und das Ganze schmeckt
richtig schön cremig und würzig und
einfach total lecker ich wünsche euch
ganz viel Spaß beim Nachbacken und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder bis
bald
[Musik]
tschüss